In one cross-test, the Hard to Destroy
Reptile SCP-682 was made to face off against
SCP-689, the terrifying Haunter in the Dark,
a statue that can induce death in anyone who
looks at it and then stops paying attention.
The statue was placed in 682’s chamber, and
the lights were turned off for five minutes.
When the lights were turned back on, 682
laid motionless in a pile of dark, grey goo.
When a D-Class was sent in to confirm the kill,
682 suddenly rose back up to its feet and devoured
him in an instant. Two swift chomps with its
razor sharp teeth, and the D-Class was history.
It seems that 682 doesn’t fit the same
definition of “alive” as us humans,
and, as a result, was unaffected by the Haunter
in the Dark. Frighteningly, 682 was also smart
enough to intuit 689’s anomalous ability and used
this knowledge to play dead and attempt escape.